- The dancing and the
choreography by the way too
- Yeah.
- are so good.
- Like
- Listen.
- Chris, Christopher Scott.
- Chris Scott, shout out Chris Scott
and all the choreo team.
- So wait, which was the hardest one?
- Hoof for me, the hardest was
dancing on the side of the building,
which forever we were like
how is that gonna happen?
There are no harnesses.
Yeah there are no
harnesses, that's fully us,
no doubles in any of these numbers
and it was, yeah.
There's pieces of my back and knee and,
Corey's back,
- Oh my God.
- And you know, our souls on that,
on that side of the
building wherever it's at
- Yeah.
- today, yeah.
- Oh my gosh,
that's so nuts.
- We put it all into it.
- That's, it.
- That's a special.
- It's incredible.
Everybody, you have to see it.